[Music]
good morning everyone
my name is heather hargit and it is my
pleasure to moderate the first session
the science of infectious diseases we'll
kick off our session
with our first speaker dr ing he is the
deputy
director of the program in emerging
infectious diseases at duke and u.s
medical school in singapore
he will be speaking to us today about
what makes us sick
the virus or our response to infection
dr ing
take it away uh hello everyone and thank
you for this opportunity to
share some of our work with you um my
name is
i'm a professor and deputy director at
the program in emerging infectious
diseases at duke in u.s
and i also co-direct the viral research
and experimental medicine center at
singh health us
academic medical center and today i'm
going to basically talk about our work
on trying to understand
what makes people sick when infected
with a virus
now take you through some uh you know
starting from coveit and all the way to
some of the experimental work that we're
doing
so you know starting with covet i mean
that probably needs no
introduction every one of us of course
know about this disease and the virus
that emerged
the end of last year or called sas
coronavirus 2 or sasko v2 for short um
starting first in china and then now
expanded all throughout the world
um in singapore if we saw our first few
cases in late january
uh in this slide we i was showing you
the first three cases that were seen
in singapore general hospital case one
incidentally was the very first case in
singapore
and what you can see from this chest
x-ray is case one had bilateral
pneumonia
whereas case two and three had no
pneumonia they were they were completely
they had a bit of symptoms but the the
chest x-ray was completely clear
and important to note was that they were
all infected with the same virus in fact
case one and two probably shared at the
identical virus
yet one got pneumonia the other person
did not
so then what makes one person you know
get more severe
uh disease when infected with the same
virus compared to the next person
so we started to try to understand that
very early on in the course of a covet
outbreak and this is the first paper
that was published
in in our group from our group led by
eugenia
who did a lot of this work and what you
see here is a heat map
of the genes that were expressed in the
blood and these were all immune genes
so we did a panel of about 500 of these
genes and on the left hand side you can
see
that the healthy controls those were the
genes that were turned on in red
and those were genes that were turned
off in blue
and you can straight away see that in
case one two and three they were quite
the patterns were quite different from
healthy controls
and remarkably case one especially in
this part was a lot more red than uh
in cases two and three suggesting that
maybe genes that clustered into the
tolerance receptor or inflammatory
signaling pathways
were overexpressed in case one compared
to two and three
and that's very consistent with a lot of
the literature
that suggested that covet 19 is a
really an inflammatory response to sars
cov2 infection
and maybe that's what is driving disease
and if we can inhibit inflammatory
signaling then we should be fine but
actually when upon closer look at this
and you can see that actually the worst
day of disease in case one was in day
five
right it's indicated by the arrow right
at the bottom whereas the the most
the highest the day with the highest
express inflammatory genes was
on day six so actually some of the genes
actually happened after
the event right so not all genes led up
to their worst day of disease
so if you now look back at what happened
at day four that could potentially lead
to what
clinic what manifests clinically in day
five
then the only thing that we could find
quite consistently throughout the
pathway was the interleukin-1
response and il1 we know is a
pro-inflammatory
response cytokine and so both il-1 alpha
and beta in left and middle of the
graphs you can see that the
you know the blue line which is case one
was higher above the
controls which is the bar and gray right
in the middle
as well as cases two and three in the
bottom in in red and yellow
um and what you can see is that at day
four these
il1 was already much higher than control
levels and that
peaked at day five when it came down
r1 beta was highest in day 4 and then
you know
certainly above the control levels
and likewise the receptor so all that
suggests that maybe this is
you know it's not all inflammatory genes
but a specific pathway that could be
driving disease
so then next question is what drives
these pathways
and we know that you know covet 19 or
sasko v2 infection isn't the only
infection that causes this
spectrum and disease outcome and i work
mostly in dengue and i'm going to
use dengue as an example um we know that
when you know amongst say 100 people
infected with dengue only about one
third will manifest
symptoms and the remaining two thirds
will be uh
will have no symptoms whatsoever would
not even realize they're sick
or what we call asymptomatic and so the
symptomatic group is actually
the very tip of the iceberg and
certainly the severe disease is then
right at the very top whereas most
infections actually don't
not cause any symptoms so then what
differentiates
these people so we of course have been
interested in trying to understand
how the virus interacts with the whole
cell now
if you think about it viruses are the
classical parasite right because outside
of the cell they are not alive they
can't do anything on their own
they need to come inside the cell and
hijack the cell's machinery
and then replicate itself and then come
out and that's how it perpetuates itself
and once inside the cell it makes a lot
of these interactions inside the cell so
that one
it replicates itself too it suppresses
all these
host response that would otherwise kill
it right and it's an interact in
all the interactions that make it a
successful uh virus to infect humans
so then we're interested of course in
what aspects of these
these pathways underpin why some people
get sick and
what why some people do not but when you
study covet 19 you study dengue
when you enroll the patients you know
five six days would have gone by since
the time they were infected
until the time they develop symptoms and
so once you they develop symptoms yeah
you know all these processes of course
are already in place all the
inflammatory genes like the heat map
i showed you earlier on are already in
play what led up to that well the only
way you can understand that is to catch
them
right at the point where they again when
they got the infection
but that's very hard to do with with
natural infections
so to understand that we've been using
the yellow fever vaccine
to study this the yellow fever vaccine
is a live vaccine so it actually is a
live virus that will cause
a very mild infection that in most
people will not make you sick at all
right and
in some individuals about half of them
will develop a one day worth of side
effects
and these side effects is like this
flu-like illness is what i'm going to
show you here
that most people in the color in bed
here will report one day worth of
feeling a bit tired maybe a bit of
headache
some bit of joint pains and a bit of
fever
which will resolve within 24 hours and
then they're fine
what this graph shows is when the
symptoms appear so this middle line here
is the median time on which when the
the people who receive the yellow fever
vaccine will report these symptoms
and it's about the median time it's
about day six okay so six days after you
get the yellow fever vaccine virus
which causes an infection six days later
you get symptoms
so very similar to what dengue is like
right about five days
covet about five days so it takes about
five days for the virus to react to
interact with the cells
before the symptoms then appear okay so
then this gives us a model to understand
why some people get sick and some people
don't some people get symptoms and some
people do not
so right of the start we do not find an
association between the amount of the
virus in the blood versus those who get
symptoms or
those who do not right so you can see on
the graph here day three day seven
there's no significant difference
in the levels of the blood uh the virus
in the blood
as measured by rttcr uh between those
who develop symptoms in red and those
who do not have symptoms in blue
what differentiates those who go on to
develop symptoms or not at day six
is the response to the infection at day
one
right so this is the point of time which
they develop these symptoms
one day after you give the the virus
yellow fever 17d
then the host response at this time
shown over in this heat map over here
determines whether you're going to get
the symptoms or not so what you see here
ae means those who develop symptoms and
blue are those who have no symptoms
and straight away just right off the bat
if you look at this heat map
more of those in the symptom sites are
red and more of those in there
without symptoms are blue and red means
the genes are switched on and blue means
they're not
so surrounded by the you know these
trends suggest that and if you don't put
it into these pathways would suggest
that a very early within 24 hours the
activation
of the immune response then would
correlate it with
those who then go on to develop symptoms
okay suggesting that that's the process
okay then why is it that not all not
everyone developed this innate immune
response only some do and some do not
but everyone got the same same virus and
everyone got about the same amount of
virus
so why only some so obviously therefore
there must be something
at baseline before you they're even
infected with the virus there's
something going on that then
upon virus infection triggers this
process very quickly
within 24 hours because this is the
immune response the obvious thing to do
then is to ask is the
immune response activated in these
individuals who want to get symptoms
versus those who do not and the answer
is no none of the
immune genes when you measure in the
blood were significantly elevated
in the symptomatic group compared to the
asymptomatic group
so if you now take take a step back and
say okay it's not the anatomy response
let's look at all the genes that we can
measure
in the blood and then ask which ones
were higher in those with
uh which ones were higher or lower in
those who have symptoms versus those who
do not
and the answer is in this slide right so
on the left hand side are those
genes that are upregulated in other
words more expressed in those who
develop symptoms
who go on to develop symptoms and and on
the left right hand side are those genes
that were
much lower in those who go on to get
symptoms
and this is before you give the virus
and so
if you look at these pathways at the top
then what you see is the unfolded
protein response
or chaperone everything to do with er
stress or endoplasmic reticulum
stress and i'll explain what that is in
a minute and this thing called
superylation and it's related
okay so what er stress and simulation
and all that are supposed to be doing is
that your
endoplasmic reticulum or your er you can
think of it like a factory
and that's where the proteins are made
and like any factory you have to have a
quality control because
you want to know that the product that
comes out of this factory is good
right now when there is when the
products are faulty then what you
do is you go back and you say slow down
the production figure out which part of
the process is faulty
remove all the faulty product faulty
products make sure they're not
exported out and then you make sure that
all the quality controls are
in place to make that to ensure that
what comes out is good
and that's exactly er stress so it
triggers a response and it slows
everything down tries to get rid of all
those faulty products so they make sure
that everything that then comes out
is corrected on the right hand side if
you look at the top pathways there are
all these
lipid metabolism as well as krebs cycle
citric
acid cycle or trichoboxic acid cycle
activity which is in the mitochondria
right so the one hand it seems like your
cells are more stressed on the other
hand energy
levels uh or needs a menu production of
energy
using through this tca cycle is now
lower
in these individuals that go on to get
symptoms
so that was done in the clinical trial
settings these are all humans there
these are not animals so
[Music]
um and they were healthy at baseline
right and so we did that in a clinical
trial to make sure that that was not
unique to one cohort we did it again
in a separate trial so what you see is
trial one trial two
and the results are reproducible across
the two trials right
again the the er stress as as indicated
by upr and so mylation
and the second one we measured specific
genes in this er stress pathway again
they are significantly higher
in the red which are those who went on
to get symptoms versus the blue
likewise metabolism except that the
lipids now
if you take all the genes in this in
these pathways
then there's that there's there's no
significant difference
in in the symptomatic versus asymmetric
group
but the tca cycle is still lower
in those uh still lower in those who
went on to get symptoms
right and across two trials so so then
what's happening in fact
the the the difference between the
difference in the expression of these er
stress
uh genes in the er stress pathways as
well as the
tca cycle is so different that you could
actually predict the outcome
right so what you see here is the the
the roc analysis uh
um and and and these are the area under
the curve value so it's about 0.7 they
are all
significant the way to look at uh auc is
that if it's an
inverted l it's a perfect test for this
uh for a condition
uh and this this red line here dot dot
uh dotted line is where there's
absolutely no difference
right and so the the the more it's skews
towards this perfect l the better the
test
so what you see here across all these
three genes in these three different
pathways
is that they're not perfect but they do
corre predict the outcome
uh in into a reasonable extent
right so and so this is before you even
got the virus
so the next question is um you know
these are all
genes can we measure
actual substances that's um
as a consequence of the differences in
these gene expression of these genes
and so because the metabolism was
involved we then
did a metabolome analysis so we measured
all the metabolites in the blood
and again what you see here on the left
hand side is you know the the different
groups right so
um in purple and and in light blue here
which is right at the bottom
are those who go on to deliver symptoms
versus
those who did not get symptoms and this
before they got the yellow fever vaccine
infection
and this is one day after again you see
that the segregation is almost perfect
right there's
no almost no overlap in these groups
that you can tell those
who want to develop symptoms versus
those who did not
before you even give them the vaccine
and if you ask okay amongst all these
metabolites which ones
is the most significant and it turns out
that is the tca cycle
so tca cycle of krebs cycle as we know
it is a way in which we process
our glucose or sugar and then uh all the
way to making energy
right um and so the tca cycle is
represented over here you know the
glucose is metabolized but the pyruvate
and then eventually to form acetal coa
which is then
all these processes are then in happens
in the mitochondria
and so if you look at the key
metabolites in this pathway
citrate isocitrate and malate they're
all lower
and those who go on to develop symptoms
versus those who did not
these were all measured by mass spec
so we also measured them in a separate
method just make sure that it's not
unique to one method but in a separate
method you can still see a significant
difference
in the citrate levels and that because
the starting
the starting point is glucose we also
measured glucose in the blood and there
was no difference in
glucose levels suggesting that for some
reason
the tca cycle activity in these
individuals are lower
in those who go on to develop symptoms
from infection
so to summarize everything that i've
talked about so far
if you give the yellow fever 17d vaccine
to
say 100 people about half of them will
develop symptoms
and those those these 50 symptoms
they do so because at one day after
vaccination
they trigger an innate immune response
and the reason why they do so is because
they have at baseline before you even
give them the
yellow fever 17d vaccine they already
have some level of er stress
and it says adaptive because they can
adapt to it
it's not overwhelming that they can
manage it and
part of the adaptation may be a reduced
tca cycle activity
okay so then how does this lead to this
so what happens after you give what
happens you get infected with the virus
is obvious right because the virus now
needs to replicate
to replicate it needs to make new copies
of itself
and what the protein shell is a critical
part as well as
enzymes to replicate the genome and so
the first thing that the top pathway
in 24 hours after you give the the virus
if you look at all the genes that
happens that are turned on in the body
then translation is taught right so it
makes new proteins
but also tca cycle it needs energy to
replicate the virus
so everything else the rest are all down
but these three pathways are exactly
what
is related to what happens at baseline
so in other words if you put all that
information together
then if in those individuals at baseline
before infection they
already have some level of er stress
they compensate for the er stress by
reducing the energy activity
energy production through mitochondrial
activity
then upon infection which increases
translation
and therefore protein production and and
because the virus needs energy so it's
going to turn
all these energy pathways on it's going
to
increase er stress further and it's
going to increase the energy demand
now that the cells cannot compensate so
it goes into this thing called the
maladaptive er stress it just kills
itself so something is in here so wrong
the quality control is cannot be managed
it will just shut down and it kills
itself
it go undergoes this program cell death
um
and so the key pathway in which it does
this is through the reactive oxygen
species or ros response
so if you come back to our our cohort of
volunteers
if you look at in blue those who do did
not develop symptoms versus those who
did
uh in red then this is a way of
measuring for ros response it's a
byproduct of it called the methionine
sulfoxide which is
present in the blood and so before
vaccination and after vaccination or
after infection
you see a significant increase in
methionine suffoxet levels compared to
[Music]
those who develop no symptoms which is
uh there's no difference in this cohort
another way of measuring ros is to
measure again a byproduct of superoxide
dismutase again you don't see a
difference in those
without symptoms but you do see a
significant difference in those who go
on to develop symptoms
then finally at the genetic level how we
our cells control the ros response
is um to express a protein called
thyroidoxin
this suppresses the ros response so if
you want to turn on the rs response you
have to suppress
this thyroidoxide and it does this
through this uh
protein called txnip or thyrodoxin
interacting protein
this then binds to this and then then it
stops this from
from functioning and so then the ros is
triggered
so if again if you then ask at the
genomic level whether tx nip
is increased in expression in those who
have symptoms and those who
without one day after
infection many answers yes so across
both trials
you can see that the red dots which are
those who are developed symptoms
are much higher than those who do not
develop symptoms
in fact the if you then ask at baseline
the er stress genes if you take
all of it and give it a score they are
it is correlated with the tx nip level
one day after they are infected and this
applies to both the er
er stress as well as the simulation
genes right
so if i put all this together and now
summarize this
uh what happens that at baseline in
those individuals with er stress then
when you're infected with a virus then
that virus is going to need to make more
copies of itself
to do that it needs to increase the
translation activity in the endoplasmic
reticulum
as well as it needs energy and in those
who already have
some level of er stress and they are
trying to adapt to that
then this additional demand on er
as well as energy then tips of the cells
over into maladaptive er stress
triggers an rrs response the res then
triggers the immune immune response
that then eventually cascades the
symptoms
so finally i just want to come back to
this point and
okay so then why is it that some people
have increased
er stress and lowered tca cycle activity
before they're
even infected so what what what drives
that
so we don't know the true answer yet but
i think there are several factors
first of all obviously genetics maybe
some of us are more
genetically susceptible to these states
bmi and i'll show you some data
preliminary data on that age perhaps
because we know that in
aging er stress increased and
and energy levels go down and maybe
that's all associated with this
and maybe that's why can covet 19
patients the older you are the worse the
disease
possibly the microbiome uh we we don't
really know how the microbiome
affects or interacts with the immune
system in general but we know it does
but the detail the mechanisms and all
that are still unclear at the stage
and perhaps also others that are not
listed here
so so just to give you an idea we have
we would love to explore the impact of
age on er stress and
tca cycle activity and how it then
affects infection outcome
but we have not been able to do that
what we have done is go back to our data
and look at bmi
and and so we do see an association
between bmi
as indicated in the x-axis and a couple
of genes in er stress pathways and these
are all
positively correlated so the higher the
bmi the more er stress
genes are expressed and then we also
we also found that if the bmi is higher
or at least amongst the symptomatic
subjects
after they'd received the yellow fever
vaccine
they have a an average a higher bmi than
those
who did not develop symptoms in fact if
you stratify our cohort by bmi
they can see that the proportion that
develops symptoms after
uh being given the yellow fever vaccine
is is
is increased with increasing bmi right
so so there's unpublished data but and
we hope to be able to
follow up with uh follow this up with
with additional studies and understand
you know why how bmi affects your stress
and and
eventually symptomatic outcome and
certainly you know obesity has been
suggested to be a risk factor for covet
19 as well
so coming back then to this summary um
we know that this is uh
okay that there's a baseline
susceptibility factor a symptomatic
outcome
right and then and it's partly it's
driven by this innate or in the immune
response or the inflammatory response
that eventually leads to symptoms
um so if given what i said then if you
think about it then really the way to
treat disease is to really target this
host response right
but actually if you think the the real
trigger i mean although these are all
susceptibly affected the trigger is
still the virus
so the question is if you treat the
virus will you change these outcomes or
do you really have to go and target
the immune response or do you have the
target er stress well the answer is you
can still target the virus
and we finally managed to kind of put
all of this together because we had a
a candidate a new candidate therapy
for yellow fever and this was in a
yellow fever
antibody that we and i say we because a
tican
generated and this went to phase one
trial and because
yellow fever vaccine causes an infection
we could use that vaccine as a way of
simulating an infection rather than test
this in yellow fever patients
so this was published just a few weeks
ago in new england journal medicine
and what i the data is here so the red
line is placebo blue line is
those treated with this antibody called
ty014
the x-axis is the proportion without
symptoms so you start off at 100 of
people without symptoms then they're
infected
one day later we treated them with ty014
those who received the drugs continued
to be asymptomatic whereas those who did
got placebo
then they started developing symptoms
and eighty percent of them will
go on to develop symptoms viremia not
symptoms sorry
the pcr data is over here again you can
see that in placebo
um you know 80 percent of them develop
detectable uh almost 100 of them
develop detectable our anemia up here is
80
develop infectious viremia whereas those
who are treated had absolutely no
detectable rna or infectious virus
so the what the previous slide i'll show
you that ty 014 completely knocked down
the virus right and this is
24 hours after so in other words if you
put what i've said earlier
that all that process would have been
triggered the ros everything would have
been triggered
right and then you come in and knock the
virus out so the question is can you
still change the outcome the answer is
yes
so if you knock the virus down as i
showed in the previous slide then over
in this slide you can see that those who
got placebo
all the genes continue to be turned on
whereas if you remove the virus
they then get switched off and
correspondingly the proportion who
develops symptoms can
continue increase with placebo whereas
you if you
cease if you stop all these events then
then the symptoms disappear
so i think the the at the end of the day
the
outcome of infection is there are some
clear susceptibility factors and i think
we're just beginning to scratch the
surface
so er stress and metabolic metabolism
into
uh related factors then on top of that
when you have an infection that triggers
the
uh that the increased protein production
and energy demand then it tips the whole
cell over
and but that would suggest that maybe we
need to
dampen the initial response to prevent
disease but at the same time you can
still get rid of the virus and the
earlier you can get rid of the virus
the more of these processes you can stop
and we can make a difference in disease
outcome
so finally i just want to acknowledge
all the people who have really
contributed this work because without
them
we would not have i would not have been
able to tell you this this story
so and i finally i just want to thank
milk for the opportunity to present this
work and all of you for
the sitting through this talk thank you
very much
thank you dr ing for a fantastic
presentation
what a way to kick off this session